newly public video is shining a light on
a controversial case in Oklahoma Terrell
Ellis jr. died at the Ottawa County Jail
in October 2015
surveillance footage appears to show
workers failing to respond to his
repeated calls for help from just feet
away
Omar Villafranca spoke to Ellis's
brother and his family attorney in an
interview you'll see only on CBS this
morning he's outside the jail where
Ellis died in Miami Oklahoma
Omar what comes next well good morning
Anthony the defense will present final
briefs to the judge and then the judge
will decide if this federal case will
move forward as for the Ellis family
they want the former sheriff and they
also want the former employees here at
this jail held accountable for terral's
death and they tell me they are tired of
waiting for justice on October 10th 2015
a seemingly healthy Terrell Ellis jr.
turned himself into authorities for an
outstanding warrant for a DUI less than
two weeks later jail surveillance video
captured the sounds of his repeated
pleas for help over several days from
his isolated cell in the roughly one
hour of video obtained by CBS News
several employees can be seen and heard
walking by his cell and locking as he
screams 12 days after he arrived Ellis
died of sepsis and pneumonia
he was only 26 years old I know he was
one to turn himself in because he was
trying to better himself
Garrett Ellis says his brother Terrell
wanted to turn his life around for his
young son after a string of run-ins with
the law including convictions for
driving with a suspended license and
drug possession during our interview he
watched the surveillance video for the
first time he says he couldn't stand to
watch it for even a minute he saw a
little clip yeah why did you stop well
just just hearing hearing the voices of
my brother is just it's just too hard
to hear him in that much pain at the
heart of the lawsuit our moments like
these former jail nurse Teresa Horne can
be heard screaming at Terrell about
faking an illness less than four hours
before he was found unresponsive in his
cell she told Ellis EMS had found
nothing wrong with him
what did you think of the way the nurse
was talking to him it was inappropriate
yeah she completely neglected his health
we had contact from inmates and then we
had contact from family members who were
who were really concerned about what had
happened to Tara because he had gone
into jail healthy Ellis family attorney
dance Mullen is now leading the wrongful
death and negligence lawsuit against the
jail former employees who have since
left and the sheriff's office I think
that the entire jail staff should have
been charged with some form of
manslaughter criminal criminally yeah
absolutely I think that a jury will
ultimately find that Terrell civil
rights were violated in the most extreme
way what was your reaction to seeing it
I was floored County Sheriff Jeremy
Floyd is named in the lawsuit he wasn't
working there when Terrell died but says
the jail's medical protocols are now
some of the best around the sheriff's
office runs to jail what does that
justice look like what should happen to
you and your Jail in your opinion in my
opinion I think a civil right violation
investigation should occur several
employees in that video including the
nurse Teresa Horne no longer work at
this jail and it's worth noting that
Teresa horns attorney told us quote the
videos do not show the complete picture
and are only one piece of potential
evidence we have also learned that the
FBI has contacted the family attorney
and they are interested in learning more
about this case Tony a complete picture
not that's a terrible way to die Omar
thank you very much little part we see
on the videotape is very upsetting and
when you can hear that he's crying for
help and it seems to be ignored that's
very tough yeah not be a complete
picture but it's not a pretty picture
not a pretty one you're right
all right Omar thank you very much